he's banned to Paul Tibbets flew the
airplane that dropped the atomic bomb
over Hiroshima during World War two
today is a retired Air Force Brigadier
General he discusses his book the return
of the Enola Gay it's about 50 minutes
I'm gonna introduce to you now General
Paul W Tibbets who as most of you know
helped to organize and train the five-o
ninth composite group which worked
closely with the logistical and
operational aspects of the Manhattan
Project he was the commander of the
Enola Gay which dropped the first atomic
bomb in human history and he is the
author of the return of the Enola Gay
now in revised edition published by Mid
Coast marketing 1998 we are going to see
about a 14 minute video narrating a
number of the events that are pertinent
to general Tibbets and thereafter he
will be available to answer questions
that you have about the events on the
video or more general aspects of his
career involvement thank you doctor vast
ladies and gentlemen as you can see I
have the hell of a hard time hearing I
have to be punched I don't know what the
man said about me but I'm sure I
deserved every word of it
I'm delighted to be here we're gonna
have some fun this afternoon I've never
stood in front of an academic group and
made any remarks or anything or I'd be
more polished like doctor bestest I'm
just one of those guys that rolls up my
sleeve and I get out and say here we go
we're going to show you right here to
start with a 14 minute film now this
film was made several years ago by a
visual arts company up Connecticut
called the Greenwich workshop and the
reason that the grant workshop did this
because of a man that they had in that
it was most interested in history and so
forth
the proposition was that we as members
of the two airplanes would be in
interviewed someplace throughout a
period leading up to about five years
ago these people came to me and said
look we don't believe everything that
we've heard these people who interviewed
you and so forth and so on
anything that you said to a recorder and
been transcribed and then stated we
don't believe half of that either would
you like to have the public hear the
truth from youth people as to what you
actually felt in like in those days when
you were in the 5 or 9th compositor
group the answer was obviously yes
because I had been dismayed by some of
the stuff that was being written as far
from the truth is 180 degrees now on the
basis of that they made this film with
us it's no rehearsal don't ask that
every day told us we're not going to
tell you what to do we don't have a
script you guys get together and you
talk you're gonna see the fellas they're
in their senior years because of the
recent time but on the other thing hand
if you could just imagine taking 30 to
40 years off of them they were a hell of
a bunch of guys I'm telling you and
you're going to get that when I come
back I'm going talk a few minutes about
the 509 composite group but then I hope
in the meantime between the film and
words I can tell you that you will come
up with some questions because I would
like to tell you what you want
rather than what I think you should hear
the films going to start when I get out
of here and you excuse me but I've seen
this thing several times now go out and
then I'll come back who's going to run
the machine oh your doctor okay
okay obviously people in the middle will
have the best shot
[Music]
[Music]
when we went overseas realize this in
June my letters to home I'm telling my
folks that I'll be there a year I did
what I thought
now I do know my friends were in the
Navy of it they thought it was a long
war they thought it was going to last at
least another year
I think olives at that time thought it'd
been a long war and a jury or a mean war
and a killing
each island we got closer to Japan's the
casualties in free
[Music]
yeah I understand joy bacteria
people in the service we didn't we just
clearly fed up with it under those
conditions if we consume anything to
significantly shorten the war and as
well I think anybody would have jumped a
possibility we can talk to young people
talk to explain it to them and things
but until they've been involved in it
they just didn't understand what a total
country effort this was what was and
everybody was involved in it not just
the people in the service although that
involved just about everybody between
the ages of 18 and 35 but the people
working in the homefront building
airplanes building banks building
weapons of war that's all it was
we're in general an office that he is
instructing me as to my assignment you
are going to organize and train a unit
to drop these atomic bombs
simultaneously in both Europe and Japan
and he told me about my views in my
world my code word of silver plate and
caution me he said Paul you got a
tremendous amount of possibilities a
tremendous amount of authority be
careful of how you use it
I would never challenge nobody ever
asked me can I drop the bomb or you know
have you made a decision to drop it if
the head on told me is just ever made
the first ever but that won't be me Paul
told us we were going to drop a new type
of weapon he said that if anybody wanted
to back out nothing would be safe
nobody backed out I was brought into the
Radio Shack
you're supposed to be Colonel Tibbets
radio operator how many hours have you
had in the air I said Tim radio school I
was naive so I didn't know what I was
supposed to expect wind over you Tom
appeared to me when I got there is the
ideal location isolated out on the
Nevada state line
on the salt flats of Utah and it wasn't
very much there there was nothing to
attract any particular attention out
there and I thought this this is the
place I want to be it would be easy to
keep the secrets that went over
don't worry ever mention the word
nuclear nobody ever mentioned the word
atomic we just knew it was got to be a
big explosion a lot of destructive force
doing the bomb Rondon test we're trying
to get the ballistics for the two
weapons whether the airspeed you'd have
to put in a different drift it out
putting different trail which is a how
far the bomb where it comes out behind
the airplane but it took me I'd say two
to three months the background I had to
actually realize and believe that they
were actually onto something as big as
I'd heard both of my background work
means these lies it's one bomb could do
what they said my organisation
fiberglass composite group was ready to
go to war by the month of May 1945 and
fight that's the word is to move the
five or night's organization overseas
[Music]
possible emergencies and everything
before they had an atom bomb in airplane
and were really playing for peace
I wanted the Japanese to see individual
airplanes I wanted them to think maybe
that most of those single airplane that
they were looking at were recovered to
Germany because they weren't interested
in reconnaissance airplanes at that time
Arush shovel was definitely a military
objective it was also the police in
which they were assembling all of their
military equipment to resist an invader
we were given information about the air
sea rescue units and what we would do in
case of trouble with the bomb trouble
with the airplane troublesome enemy
action had the final briefing at that
midnight followed by that new breakfast
and down the flight line you knew it was
big it was it was going to be a big one
and so your I think you were at a level
a little higher than you do on a
conventional mission the biggest part of
that after the briefing was coming out
to the aircraft and seeing this
tremendous amount of people around it
played lights with shining all over the
airplane a big crowd of people out there
who you were a center of attention you
were the monkeys in the zoo I was
sitting there in the seats ready to
start engines and of course some of the
cameras were still out there
and I stuck my head out there asked them
please move move the cameras and the
floodlights and all that so we could
start cranking up and at the same time
somebody yelled at me said hey wave at
us I had a bunch of lives on board this
airplane that I had to give careful
consideration to and in that regard I
couldn't help but reflect on chaplet
down his prayer
beep ready at the end of the war may
come soon and then once more we may know
peace daughter be the man who died this
night be kept safe inside care and may
they be returned safely to us we shall
go forward trusting him be knowing that
we are denied care now in the name of
Jesus Christ amen
now what gear indicator for past 160
last night and we're still on the rounds
over wheels were turning but I was
confident that this was the only way to
do it so that I could control with the
tail if I had to so when I'm going down
there and I kept the past that magic
hundred and forty that he's literally
used to he started to grab the yoke and
pull back but he said lift it all and I
told him I said if your damn hands off
to that you don't fly this airplane
weather was very clear we could see the
coast of Japan from probably 75 to 100
miles away and I thought I went up and
looked over Tom's shoulder and we took
compared notes in the city and make sure
he had the right target and picked out
the a pitch of the was the aiming point
then I went back and sat down and it was
in the palm of your hands at that point
but after flying it much I had Europe
and planning mission from the very start
I knew a lot about picking up aiming
points or something I I could pick up at
the bomber here real easy and that the
bridge I picked out was right in the
moment instead of the city I made an
ideal aiming point and then for five
minutes
I was watching his head there and you'd
look at immediate sewer on a cigar he
said ain't a damn thing I can do nothing
it's going right down the track did you
look up at the bomb site it's on course
and it was on course until it left
airplane oh I raised up little and
looked out right out over the nose and
Paul immediately started to turn but I
could still see it but I want to make
sure it was clear the aircraft but I had
some trouble of something that tumbled
here that I was
the wind overtop them so I want to make
sure it's falling clear and it was it
was going straight in and we were still
pretty close to within the mushroom
cloud she showed the cloud rising to
about our level which was a neighborhood
of 33,000 feet if I remember right and
it also showed the turbulence from
gulping the city and moving out into the
foothills and the only thing that I
could see the Ferrari Sherman was one of
the docks and the pay penalty bats would
you tell us some of your reactions over
the target well as the bomb left the
airplane we took over manual patrol made
it an extremely steep turn to try and
put as much distance between ourselves
and the explosion as possible after we
felt the explosion hit the airplane that
is the concussion waves we knew that
bomb had exploded everything was a
success so we turned around to take a
look at it the sight that greeted her
eyes was quite beyond what we had
expected because we saw this cloud of
boiling dust and debris below us with
its tremendous motion
beneath that was hidden the ruins of the
city of Hiroshima when we came back we
knew that war was over there was no way
that war could keep going on what we
thought had happened but they would not
admit to the fact they didn't admit to
Hiroshima they finally admitted to
Nagasaki but even after they gave up
ceded they didn't they didn't show any
overt acts to stop the war so it was
necessary to have two bombs and I think
that we back on the ground that didn't
buy the second mission we're pretty
doggone proud of that group of people
too I think you have to say that you
wish the war could have ended without
flying missions of this type but in the
long run I'm thoroughly convinced that
the use of the this weapon did shorten
the war and save lives overall both
allied lies and Japanese lies because if
you look at if you play what if and you
say what would have happened if the bomb
had not haven't dropped and you start
looking at you know fire bombs would
have continued even down invasion the
casualties have been very very heavy war
advance Harville and even in Europe my
intention though that are the same thing
as Hiroshima was that forget the war in
the killing it's a devastating thinking
it came as a tremendous surprise it
shocks people if people conceived
the attitude that we have if patriotism
we had at the time the sincerity of our
beliefs today I wanted to do everything
that I could to subdue Japan that was
the attitude of the United States and oh
here's that 509 composite group was a
great group of patriotic men they all
put their backs to the wheel and we
succeeded in bringing that carnage to an
end and everybody got to go home
[Music]
[Music]
Jerell Paul Tibbets thank you thank you
thank you very much a way to give you a
few words about this 509 composite group
before that I've been to how I got
involved in the thing to give you a
quick synopsis of what I did during the
war
I got into b-17 in a hurry I was in 17s
in December 41 at the end of didn't
coming better there's no PA okay
there's no PA so I thought hey I can
talk okay ah I forgot what I was gonna
say that's terrible
I think I'll think of something else the
idea was important to give you an idea
of what my background was to answer a
question has been asked to tell hundreds
of times and I said I didn't know in
other words how did you get selected for
this project I said I didn't know I was
told that's what it was I saluted and
left you know
after I've been told what it was now in
September 44 I was very happily in those
did testing their vulnerability of a
b-29 to fighter attack in conjunction to
the University of New Mexico they had a
an airplane their b-29 it had camera
guns on it because I had turrets it was
a regular combat airplane am I getting
out a regular combat airplane and that
airplane on a particular day had lost
two engines that was found out when they
landed for their from their flat for the
day on attract 25,000 feet in 25 miles
in length for
fighters to come in and attack and
photographs to be made and all that but
gun cameras on both airplanes that thing
broke the the b-29 did well I got called
real quick to come in what is going you
know can you do anything to expedite the
changes of these engines and I said no I
there's take so much time to change them
and I can't expedite anything quiet and
dr. workman he was the head of the
physics department of University of New
Mexico and he was the man that had this
government project to produce this
description of what the vulnerabilities
were or were not and I said oh my god he
said today's the last day of my program
and it's so important to have this and I
said well looking I arrived in here in a
b-29 flying machine
it had no turrets it had nothing but
it's got four engine on it and don't fly
he said I don't care about you know any
guns on the airplane on your bomber
airplane I got all I need on the
fighters makes short short I got the
airplane went into the air with it after
being briefed and flying the track and
all that sort of thing that they wanted
I was flying along they're just happy as
hell after about an hour an hour and a
half had on autopilot I was watching
these fighters you know they're all
fancy dudes they come in and they do
something that get him up and roll them
and they do those things I didn't pay
attention to what the airplane was doing
I was just turned it around back and
forth and all that sort of thing by the
autopilot control and I heard a couple
of boys come up and say tell him to slow
down I can't catch him tell him to slow
down my engines overheating
well him to slow down that had to mean
me so I looked at that buyer fade
indicator of course it's a little bit
higher than normal I'd burned off a lot
of gasoline in that time that I'd been
up there doing this lighten my load and
the airplane had sought its own level he
just kept going up and I was at 31,000
feet well that was six thousand feet
higher and they could get that I
registered real quick and that's my
safety factor right there next step was
I got
sign to the Manhattan Project by being
cold from that job into general insult
as he was command general second Air
Force of Colorado Springs to be
interviewed by him for something I
underwater was but did make the
difference and the Wordsworth from
Gallup from where more than a New Mexico
area
Alamogordo Field in New Mexico to
Colorado Springs I had to have I had my
before bag and so forth in the airplane
and the words were bring your v4 bag
with you because you're not going to go
back maybe you're not going to go back
to El Gordo
well that triggers something but what
the hell I had a lot of strange things
happen to me first excuse I've lost both
salary glanced I have to have water to
keep my throat lubricated it is water
too
[Laughter]
okay I arrived at gentle into office the
following morning at time specified I
walked into his secretary and identified
myself
she said yes Carl tippers we've been
expecting you and she punched your butt
button on soft box voice says yes and I
was gentle in obviously she said Colonel
Tibbets is here he said tell him to wait
a minute well okay fine
I didn't think I think about that man's
busy I waited a minute or two and out
his office comes to lieutenant colonel
with corps of engineers insignia on if
you got a bunch of books and stuff under
his arm he walks over sticks out his
hand he said I'm Jack Lex
lancedale like to ask a few question why
would a lieutenant-colonel we're in a
color of Engineers insignia water talk
to me he said there's a cloakroom over
it's kind of private let's walk over
there we could talk I said fine you've
laid out a bunch of leaves and papers
and so forth so on you asked a couple of
questions he said or he said did you say
this in Cincinnati Ohio or did you say
that or something else in Miami Florida
and so and so forth well I had said
those things that he was asking me but
it went back as far as I could remember
when I was about nine years old and that
kind of worried me but then he got up
today he got up to my proper age and the
guy looked at me see never been arrested
I said yeah he said what for I said well
no man was good to me bought me an
automobile gave me money to run it to go
to school everything else that I said
you know in the summer times when I was
not in school I have a date we'd run
over to Miami Beach or back or something
would run a little bit late I said I
stepped down on that accelerator he said
I don't mean that anything more
experience right then I knew the bastard
knew something
I said yes he said what I said well one
night I don't remember the time but one
night or early morning hours in Surfside
Surfside was almost an isolated place in
those days north of Miami Beach and I
know I said one night is Surfside I was
in the backseat of my automobile with a
young woman and we were in a hell of a
compromising position the flashlight
comes through the wind it says what's
going on in there
he started to laugh with her slapped his
leg he said that's all I wanna know he
wanted to know if I'd lied to him well I
wouldn't lie to anybody so hey he said
come on let's go see Journal in we
walked in general dentists office Tila
general Eddie said I'm perfectly
satisfied Lansdale was the chief of
security for the Manhattan district and
they had been investigating me I learned
later on they'd been investigating me
for a year and a half and that sort of
thing so fine I got I got that I got
selected because general ed said that I
was the one that he would choose when
general Arnold asked him three names
he said that Paul Tibbets is the one on
what would Matt recommend and that was
Arnold said get him so that got me into
general info us for that particular
purpose now I had had by that time I've
had about 15 months of testing b-29s one
way or another and the airplane when
they started explaining it to me dr.
Norman Ramsey nuclear physicist went in
there captain Parsons Navy captain was
there and between he Ramsdale and
Parsons he briefed me on the atom bomb
what they were doing they didn't have it
made yet but they were right at the
point they had to use airplanes so this
brings Tibbets into the picture I was a
brief completely on what I could do and
what I couldn't do
the answer was you could do anything you
want to do if you can back it up but
nobody will know whether that until
after the war is over if you've done
something wrong you you might get put in
prison if you did something for all
right but maybe nobody say anything
because all the money that were into
Manhattan
two billion dollars worth was not on the
congressional record as such it had been
attached to some other bill and fed
through by and I think it was Senator
Simpson was an elderly man he was
trusted by this congressional people
colleagues and so on and he's the one
that general Marshall knew and that's
how they got this money for to support
the Manhattan district I'm getting let
me get off for the academics let's get
down direct his real business I was to
give an instruction to organize and
train a unit it could drop these bombs
on enemy territory in Europe and Japan
simultaneously they had to be done
simultaneously because they didn't want
anything to get out they wanted to be
the surprise to be the same old or both
theaters at the same time or a kind of
Russia with that situation I had to have
I knew what I had have had that split
operation right away and generally
instead of looking you've got to have
b-29 airplanes and he said I'm going to
send a couple dole first he said there
is a squadron at Hastings Nebraska 390
third Bomb Squadron at the 500 fourth
group he said me and my people here look
at looked at the records of their
training they seem to be the best trip
between our squadron we have in training
and you go look at him if you like them
we'll send them to Wendover because I
had told him it would give me the fields
on water don't want to Wendover Utah
preference
instead of getting field in character
great Bend in Kansas and one up in North
Dakota which I don't remember but anyway
with that situation I left his office
with the word go do what you have to do
use the second Air Force as your media
to get you what you need by normal
requisitions if something is needed that
you don't have a normal requisition put
silver plate on it and send it in and
because general Arnold has said silver
plate will be honored without any
question you told a hit and
our staff without any question whatever
don't ask questions honor the
requisition now we'll proceed on a
little bit faster I got as a result of
that I got the opportunity I put in a
standard requisition for 15 b-29
airplanes I got those to be 15 I've got
those 15 b-29 airplanes without one
question and after they had been my
serial number had been allocated to me I
got a call from man that I had roomed
with in Kelly fields when we were just
getting ready to graduate down there he
was an aeronautical engineer from Purdue
and he called me said Paul this is what
Rison was his name he said I know you
got a new I got some kind of a project I
don't know what it is but you getting 15
new b-29s out of the Martin plant at
Omaha Nebraska I said good he said do
you uh would you like to have
fuel-injected engines arms carburation
was one of the biggest problems b-29s
had in those days I said you know I was
to it he said I thought so would you
like to have 15 sets of Curtiss
reversible pitch propellers to put on
them well break energy was something
that kept those b-29 from stopping when
they were loaded and started down runway
lose now board engine it couldn't
control it brakes wouldn't do it didn't
have enough wind to cost the tail to
give you that capability to turn it or
do whatever you want I said I sure would
he said I thought so I just wanted to
tell you there are 40 sets of them being
sent to Omaha for your airplanes
well that would that was a really a good
thing now I knew that the airplane was
going to be wonderful but what had to do
was head take those airplanes not
physically take them we had to get the
airplanes from Omaha the Air Force had
to buy them at Omaha then we had to take
him over to off the field of course old
there was in the confines of Omaha I say
that particularly because the factory
was not on offered field business
it was offset it was offered there and
we had I had worked with dr. work dr.
[Music]
Oppenheimer's people the ants he had
some wonderful
engineers down there and that will Los
Alamos lab they told me what they needed
which was above my head but I said okay
fine
we'd go to the manufacturer will tell
him that this is what's needed on those
airplanes manufacturer says well we
can't do it here but we'll get that
hanger and off it field they're forced
to take delivery on them pass for them
then we'll get them over to the hangar
over there and to be modified there and
it was about a three week deal to modify
each airplane what they did was they
stripped all the armored out of except
in the tail all of the turrets all of
the ammunition tracks all of these
aren't well I said armor plate so no
didn't want any armor plate around seats
or anywhere else because I knew if we
could get up there thirty one thousand
which I was sure with their field
injected inches we do that the air place
came through our delivery as they were
supposed to come not all at one time
but a few at a time two at a time I
think was the best I've learned also
because I had to be self-supporting and
that was because of security that I
would need transport airplanes and I
said in a requisition for 15 for five
c-54 airplanes transport airplanes for
engine transports yeah requisition get
back to disapprove well I took I took
thing went in and gave it to a friend of
mine in the contact man who was a friend
of mine in general Arnold's office I
called him I said hey I got this thing
so we'll give it to me she said right
silver plate on it but he said before
you do go back to see the general they
told that this road is just approval
down there and see if you tell him you
have silver plate that he will give it
to you I said fine so I went back to see
this Gerald your big fella I looked at
it I said general I need those there
please he said dammit he said they are
transport to Nancy divorced you do he
said I just gave you 15 b-29s what you
trying to do start Tibbets first
individual Air Force
I said no sir he said well this answer
goes I still disapprove but you can't
help them yes sir
I walked out of his office went back to
solve a friend the Pentagon handed him
requisition he said you gonna be here
the rest of the day I said naw my way
back to wind over
he said well going back to wind over
I'll give you a phone call a second day
for my departure my phone rang first
thing in the morning which is about 11
11 o'clock for the Pentagon and there's
my friend he said you got a pencil paper
and I said yeah he said take these down
here's the serial numbers and the date
your your c-54s will be delivered and I
took them grow five c-54s down on for
delivery and all that sort of thing I
said what happened he said well general
Arnold always had his deputy chiefs of
staff come in through the office every
morning to talk about what happened
yesterday what we're going to do today
what we're going to do tomorrow or in
the future it was a get together share
knowledge and he had to have it he
always stood in the doorway and as he
three or four star journal came through
he shook hands with a boy general sort
so but he had told this man when the
deputy for operations
you know requirements comes up tell him
the whole stay back and let his man come
in fine everybody got rid of good
morning general as he walked in Bartle
then with this other guy walked in the
man that wouldn't give me my herb lazy
look to him said good morning major
well everybody knows days had temporary
rank so he took him down from a
brigadier general he took him down to
the rank of Major and he turns around to
the others general sitting there with
her boss opens his general gentlemen I
said one time that all silver plate
acquisitions would be honored do I need
to repeat it well no I guess nobody
answered him I don't know but anyway I
never had trouble left there but I'm
going to skip a little bit in ahead of
time cuz I'm hitting and missing to give
you some key points I really took
advantage of that read you know that
silver plate name and what I did was I
went out to see general LeMay I tell him
I was coming out there with this
organization into his theater and so
close for what it was going to do and he
listened very carefully and he looked at
me say stick the damn thing will work
I said yes sir I ain't gonna work he
said if you told Admiral Nimitz of
course Nimitz was in a theater commander
I said no he said well don't you think
you oughta I said yes sir I'll tell him
so he got our telephone he called Nimitz
and I was taken over to his headquarters
introduced and I told him what that I'd
basically what I told the may and he
looked at me was very nice friendly
smile he said it's the Navy doing
everything they can to help you
sure far as I know they're doing
everything just perfect he said well if
they don't need called Kincaid c'mere
here comes the three-star ed boss he
said if you need anything for today.we
you tell Kincaid he'll get it for you
yes sir that ended that conversation I
had to bring that out now I said it were
a while ago that this was a peculiar
outfit we had to have with for the
project we had to have peculiar type
people that the Air Force didn't have an
MOS for so we had to go outside to get
it well the biggest thing I got outside
was an army military police company
because we had to have guards we had to
have tightest security in the world I
had to have people out of the heavy
maintenance group with their ability
to fix airplanes that broke because we
couldn't take them to a Depot they were
modified we had to fix your own air
place so I've got metal workers but
Charlie the chief Jules of the whole
outfit was from the Army Ordnance we got
tool and die makers because we had to
have tool and die makers in this
business to make tools for unknown
reasons and whatever didn't have a tool
like it
tell them what you needed and they do it
and I'll tell you those guys could do it
now while I'm on that one that was the
most important outfit I had that really
that is squad eight first ordnance
squadron that's what it was called and
first coordinate squadron air I I got
real concerned when my security man came
to me he was a major a very brilliant
man very capable guy then was you wanna
and he said in your organization he said
you have this is when I got this thing
all put together with their people he
said in your organization you have five
escaped felons my mouth drop he said
that's not unusual with guy getting out
of prison where can he hide any better
than a million four million man army and
I said yes that makes sense and he said
I said he said you wonder who they are I
said yeah I want to know who they are so
he laid the dossiers down to show them
two of more murderers escaped five or
four or three of or manslaughter total
five and you want to said to be do you
want to keep them and I said let me talk
to their boss and I just got on the
phone and I called him ordnance people
that I called these names out I said
those men important to you
he said God did the most important
skilled people I got so I turn around I
thank this all or no I turned around you
one and he said okay fine let's call him
in and tell him we know who they are I
said let's do that so we called him in
individually and showed them proof in
reading that
had escaped for the escape from what the
real name was and what the sentence was
and each one of them after we got
through I said to him you go back to the
squadron's keep your mouth shut and if
you continue doing the work you've been
doing when this war is over with I'll
give you these papers and a match to
burn him up and that's what they did
they never broke security than ever did
anything now security being tight I'll
tell you how tight it was out on the
island my organization was assigned to
313 Bomb Wing commanded by a brigadier
general a very nice man really nice and
he was always had has come up to his
mess or during the weekdays to see what
happened last night
what are we going to do tonight and all
that sort of stuff pass the information
around name with Jim Davies and so I was
used to that but one day I'd been out
flying on a trail of a training mission
and I came back and landed and my head
was out they said General's Office
called what know if you come up 15
minutes early and I said sure and I went
as quickly as I could
change my clothes and horseface hands I
went up to his office and when I walked
in why he said I went out to look at one
of your airplanes today I said all he
said yes he said the guard or duty
wouldn't let me look at it I said he
wasn't supposed to general you didn't
have proper pass he said I know he
that's always funny he asked me if I had
a green pass and I said to him don't I
don't need one I'm general Davies I
command this place they took out his a
Geo card and full of the guard and the
guard said said general I recognized you
I don't need to see that but you don't
have a breeding pass you can't get on
this airplane he says well I can and he
said I took one step forward that
brightful came right straight up my
belly cocked and said general one more
step and you're dead he said would he
have shot me I said there's no doubt in
my mind he would have shot you
he said I thought so let's read I come
back here and called you oh we had some
Buster's in that outfit I tell you you
want to let me them then I'm going to
get on to the business of the day this
man you wanta came to Wendover having
been at the University of Chicago been
at Chicago because they were suspicious
the security people were suspicious at
them Enrico Fermi's laboratory had a
mole in it and it did have a mole and I
said well but how did you turn that up
he saw it was simple he said they were
kind of stupid in their habits I said
what do you mean he said well he said we
listened to him three times he said I
kept all the wires in and out and all
that sort of stuff he said because he
was electrical engineer I so how'd you
get the wires tapped he said well we
just go into the office complex and I'd
get my partner to make passes at the
switchboard operated while they were
busy I'd you know I'd hook up the
listening devices I said that's a good
bit of work he said oh no he said they
always met under the same streetlight
which was about two blocks distance from
the stadium at almost the same time and
that's what would you do he said well on
this particular night they were gonna do
the same thing again and I he said what
okay what's the next move he said well
partner and I said we got in our
automobile we got down in that area we
parked it in the dark he said maybe 40
yards away and we waited for him to meet
I said did they he said yeah they met
and they exchange papers and so forth
back and forth I said well you guys he
said nothing we just took the rifles
over a bath backseat and killed the
bastard he wasn't kidding he said look
it who would anybody in Chicago give any
consideration to a couple of naked
stiffs laying in the gutter at midnight
I said I guess you got something there
but this is how serious they were they
were just as serious as could be and I
I've felt that when I had been briefed
by stat Lansdale
up in the general health office okay
there were other little nitpicking
things that came along but didn't them
out the hill of beans and but I did have
a couple of guys that went on a furlough
and couple I about five went on a
furlough after being told you know don't
do any talking when you sleep in the
barracks you don't ask the guy next to
him what he does you just do your
business and that's it
well anyway these guys left on their
furlough and to go anywhere from
Wendover Utah you have to either go to
the train station at Wendover which goes
to Salt Lake or comes from Elko Nevada
that was the media of getting ten to an
hour window with Salt Lake City either
by air car or rail and these guys had
gone home and they've been picked up
because he'd put his agents at this it
still days there at least one of them
when the guys went on their fellow and
by the time they got home there was a
message there waiting for him to return
to your orders have been changed
returned to wind over and I told him
when they came in why they were brought
back with that the next egg was what do
we gonna do about it
I told these guys I said you know you
have broken security now she said things
in the under wartime conditions I said
you go back to your Burks under arrest
you stay there and go with the mess hall
D but that's all things you can go you
keep your mouth shut because I may
decide to have you court-martialed shot
before a firing squad and it's something
they got back and then the other guys
came back calmly I just let him sweat
all this links the time the other guys
came back normally and passed the words
around and from that time on there was
never a breaking security booster from
the five or nine people they were wind
overuse or anywhere else now let's get
last thing to do we had to test these
first off the beat Ryan I squadron that
I got from training command 390 third
Bomb Squadron a bunch of good guys they
had good spirit and when I first briefed
them after arriving there to be quiet
there goes we're going to go into
training we're going to teach you this
we're going to teach you that
said we don't need that we've already
done it I said you have done it to my
surgery to my specifications I don't
know whether you have or not but we're
this what I'm gonna do we're gonna fly
an airplane at 25,000 feet at night
we're gonna go out over this and land
where there's no lights no radio signals
or no nothing you're going to navigate
by the stars at night you're gonna use
sun lines in the daytime he said well
it's impossible to get there back I've
told me they'd have to do that they have
to come back and close their triangular
course with no more than a quarter of a
mile separation between the closures and
you had to drop the bomb within 500 feet
of the aiming point they they said it's
impossible you can't do it I said well
it is possible and we're going to do it
fair B Van Kirk and I took squadron
commanders what a navigator squadron
bombardier up and we flew one of these
things for them with the navigator
Watson what was going on the Bombardier
watching this quarter commander watching
me and we did just exactly that Tom
dropped this bomb of 327 feet from the
target oh no this was a hundred pounds
right 500 pound practice bomb so it was
legal to do that and we did the whole
Sultan desert out there to do it and it
worked real well now that you went back
this apparently charged the batteries
because the first thing that I found out
was we got to beat the old man I was the
thing that they had to beat and I smiled
I did I got what I wanted and on the
basis of that we had a lot of fun they
were very good and at the final part of
their training I sent him down to
Bautista field in Havana Cuba because
the commander down there was man I had
known for a long time and I said we sent
him down there to get out over water
because you have a different problem
dropping bombs where you come from water
to land or land to water it's this
perspective is different and the Box Tom
told me this I'm not above a deer but
Tom said it's the same thing it's not
too much of an error but it is an error
and I said that's fair enough
well with that situation they got down
there and they became very competitive I
had I had three squatters there at a
time and though in one time I went I
went
Dallin every time they were down there I
went to see them just about the time
they'd been there for two weeks they're
getting ready to leave and within a week
and so I could say I visited each group
of three and I went down there one time
and towards the end of the thing
the commander terraces looked at me said
well said where's the fun last night I
said we beat he said how much money if
you got spare that's what you mean
he said how much he just your surplus
month money for funds and so funds from
to do things I said well I don't I don't
have any I don't have one I said why he
said well last night your guys down
there such-and-such a hotel they got so
carried away with their battle as who
was the best crew they got into the
hotel using fire axes and water hoses
and he said I gotta buy a whole new
hotel in furnish it and I said oh boy he
said don't worry about it I got the
money we'll fix it
he said just ask him not to have one of
those things every time they come I said
fair enough
Brigadier General Paul Tibbets is
retired from the Air Force his book the
return of the Enola Gay is about his
experiences working with the Manhattan
Project and his pilot of the Enola Gay
the plane that dropped the atomic bomb
over Hiroshima the book is published by
Mid Coast marketing visit the web